hi dark in here it's presently this
lighting actually looks pretty good for
being dark it's probably like a SM 1200
so I'm glad that a lot of you guys
enjoyed my previous day in the life
video I enjoyed reading some of your
comments and a lot of you guys were like
why did you choose this music why is
this so depressing are you alone are you
sad are you depressed what's wrong can
we help you why didn't you choose happy
hair music I don't understand I'm so
confused what is going on what's that
song kind of feel like this video turned
into a subtle commentary of how YouTube
is sort of is for some content creators
I kind of think it might be actually
most of us to be honest with you
although a lot of people have teams
around them that film and shoot and edit
their videos but most of the time most
youtubers I know and myself included we
still edit and shoot all of our own
stuff all by ourselves that video was
pretty much my morning later that day I
went to a party hung out with friends
and had a really great time people show
you what we want you to see we don't
show you the things that we don't want
you to see so that particular day that I
was filming that I was feeling kind of
sad that video kind of for me portrayed
how I was actually feeling nothing
particular was wrong I'm okay I just
think a lot of times when you're making
YouTube videos you don't really see who
people are also to further sort of the
message that I was trying to hit home at
the end of that video I was talking
about trying to be perfect and somehow
the YouTube video processed improperly
and the video glitched pretty much all
the way through the end normally what
happens I usually will just take it down
and bring you upload it but I didn't I
just left it I feel like it really kind
of drove the point home just a little
bit more of sometimes you can't control
things and you just kind of have to let
it go anyway speaking of that day I went
to Matt's apartment housewarming party
and I never posted the blog so let's go
check out that vlog
Matthew it's time to pack up your body
the dog wallet where's my GoPro the
GoPro is not here well I'm for that I
found it
we're gonna go see Jenna let's go get
that got you going real good hey peanut
butter pick look at your little face
guess what we're in the car car vlogs
we're on our way I've got some cupcakes
in the back I'm pretty excited about it
because there's a new thing that I got
really good look at these nice there you
go you don't even I don't I'm glad JD's
not here because he would go straight
for this one of those that they do
actually look actually you know what
yeah everyone else is accessory
yeah everyone a half I wouldn't do that
is supposed to be a frank bread but it
just didn't work out so well but this is
movement as
haste oh no the same movement Matt he's
losing his mind over here are you
enjoying the party
he's silly you think I know today we're
gonna be making some earth today cookies
[Music]